the coin of aries second of his name
had landed on madness
but half the coins of the targaryens had
landed so
yet only ares would be known as the mad
king
thanks in no small part to the defiance
of duskendale
duskendale was the greatest port on
blackwater bay until aegon built king's
landing
as the capital grew richer and more
prosperous
it sucked ships and gold away from
duskendale
to halt its long decline
the lord of duskendale sir dennis
darklin petitioned king aerys for a
royal charter that would allow him to
levy his own port fees and taxes which
would obviously be lower than in king's
landing
the hand of the king tywin lannister
refused
but knowing of the tension between the
hand and its king sir dennis invited the
king to duskendale to evaluate his
petition himself rather than deferring
to his hand
when tywin admonished the king to refuse
as any sensible adviser would
a petulant and bristling air is instead
accepted
traveling to duskendale with a small
retinue and only one of his kingsguard
as soon as aerys stepped within the city
sir dennis seized him killing the
kingsguard and the few others who dared
to defend their king
aerys was hauled to the dungeons to have
his beard pulled and have other petty
cruelties inflicted on his royal person
lord tywin immediately raised an army
and marched on duskendale but the dennis
threatened to kill the king at the first
signs of an assault
if sir dennis hoped to force tywin to
offer terms he didn't know lord tywin
who refused to even parley until sir
dennis released the king and surrendered
the royal army surrounded the city and
the royal navy blockaded it
so dennis had clearly not anticipated
such obstinacy
nor that the king's hand would be in no
rush to save the maddening king when as
lord tywin himself pointed out
the realm had a better option in the
king's much more stable son prince
rhaegar
after six months lord tywin's patience
was at an end or at least none could
claim he acted recklessly if he now
stormed the city and sir dennis killed
the king
but the dutiful and honorable sir
barristan the bold volunteered to
infiltrate the city and rescue his king
single-handedly as befit his kingsguard
oath
tywin couldn't refuse such valor
publicly
and so begrudge sir barristan one night
then he would storm the city and put
every man woman and child to the sword
with only his hands
sir barristan climbed the city walls in
the dark of night and snuck through the
city disguised as a beggar evading
patrols and suspicious townspeople
when he reached the walls of the city
keith the dun forward he scaled those by
hand as well
even dispatching the wall guard before
he could sound an alarm
with incredible bravery and luck sir
barristan made his way to the dungeons
and freed his king
then sir barristan's luck ran out
the cry went up through the castle
someone had discovered the king was gone
with horns and trumpets blaring an alarm
sir barristan cut their way to the
stables avenging his slain guard brother
but taking an arrow to his chest
slipping through the castle gate just as
it closed
the wounded sir barristan and aries rode
through the rails town racing for the
city walls and beyond it the safety of
the royal army
lord tywin's archers raced forward to
clear the walls of defenders
and sir barristan the bold earned
immortality by delivering king aerys to
the waiting if not welcoming arms off
his hand
without his hostage sir dennis
surrendered and begged mercy from the
same king he'd imprisoned
most men would have had none ares had
less
he commanded sir dennis to be executed
along with any man woman or child who
bore his family name and anyone who once
had
as for sir dennis's foreign wife who had
urged his defiance aries commanded that
her tongue and womanly parts be torn out
and she be burned alive
it was his first time passing such a
sentence
it must have given him a taste for it
for the king rescued from duskendale was
not the same king who'd entered it
many men would crack after six months in
a dark cell being mocked prodded and
tweaked
aerys had arrived cracked
now he was shattered
for years he would refuse to leave the
red keep encouraged now died by his
worried advisors
since he also refused to allow any
blades near his person even to shave his
beard cut his hair and trim his nails he
began to see enemies in every shadow who
vanished
only when the fires burned
aerys targaryen was the last of his name
to sit on the iron throne
known far and wide as the mad king
his was a reign of instability and
terror
the seven kingdoms are well rid of him
and his kind
oh he may have appeared to be a capable
ruler at first but that was due in no
small part to his counselors led by the
hand of the king tywin lannister
there may have been years of peace and
prosperity during aerys reign
but it was tywin who was really running
the country as eris spiraled further and
further into insanity
the dragons spawn were famous for losing
their minds
it was the price they paid for centuries
of keeping the bloodlines pure
and eris more than happily continued the
noble
sister
tradition of his forefathers
as the years passed erys's behavior
became increasingly erratic
he cut himself so often on his iron
throne many referred to him as king scab
though never to his face
it was rumored he had developed an
obsession with wildfire and was known to
inflict horrific punishments on those he
considered enemies
including burning them alive
as his paranoia and bloodlust grew
he had a bitter falling out with lord
tywin who had served the crown
faithfully for 20 years
at least tywin was able to leave the job
with his life and fortunes intact
subsequent hands of king aerys weren't
so fortunate
then the targaryens went too far the
crown prince rhaegar abducted lyanna
stark daughter of rickard stark the lord
of winterfell
she was my betrothed
she was my beloved
beautiful and spirited woman
and i loved her more than life itself
rhaegar went south with lyanna hiding
her away in dawn
what harm he inflicted on the poor girl
the gods only know
brandon stark lyanna's eldest brother
was outraged
he rode to king's landing to confront
the king
and demand his sister's safe return
instead aerys had him executed his
father rickard stark as well
there wasn't much left to discuss after
that
heiress feared their loved ones would
seek revenge for what he did
he was right to be afraid
heiress wasted no time in calling for
the heads of brandon's younger brother
my friend eddard stark
and my head too of course
i'm sorry he didn't come looking for it
himself
alongside john aaron of the vale the man
who fostered ned and i as children
baratheons starks and tully's all called
their banners
once our rebellion began
the mad king's days were numbered
as word of king harry's erratic and
troubling behavior spread throughout the
seven kingdoms
lord rickard stark continued to serve
his king faithfully as warden of the
north
the proud father of four children his
daughter lyanna was engaged to robert
baratheon
the young lord of storm's end
centuries of peace between the north and
the iron throne
ended the day rhaegar targaryen prince
of dragonstone
abducted lyanna
enraged brandon stark rode to king's
landing demanding the release of his
sister and the death of rhaegar
aries arrested him for treason
and called his father to come to the
capitol to ransom him
when lord rickard complied ayer is now
utterly mad arrested him for treason as
well
lord rickard demanded a trial by combat
aries declared fire the champion of
house targaryen and had lord rickard
suspended from the rafters of the throne
room while pyromancers lit a blaze
beneath him
as he burned brandon was brought into
the throne room
a leather cord attached to a
strangulation device was wrapped around
his neck
aries told brandon his father was a dead
man
but there was a chance to save him
a long sword was placed on the floor
just out of brandon's reach
and the more he struggled to reach it
the more the cord tightened around his
throat
brandon stark strangled himself trying
to free his father
who was roasted alive in his own armor
the entire court stood and watched this
atrocity take place
so jamie lannister and the kingsguard
among them
the mad king was reported to have
laughed hysterically as these two noble
men were tortured and brutally killed
before him
seeking to rid the world of all his
supposed enemies
heiress called for the head of rickard's
younger son eddard stark
and lyanna's betrothed robert baratheon
he sent word to lord john erin who'd
fostered both young men and the eerie to
apprehend them
instead
lord aaron joined houses stark and
baratheon in rebellion
robert vowed to kill rhaegar targaryen
and get his belovedly honor back
as aries targaryen's behavior grew more
and more erratic the task of ruling the
seven kingdoms fell to me timing
lannister
i had served aries for nearly 20 years
and as a result the realm had prospered
the royal coffers were full the land was
at peace
but aries grew increasingly hostile
jealous of the success many credited to
me
my power and influence unnerved him
the captain of my personal guard sir
ellen payne was once overheard making
offhand comments regarding who was the
true ruler of westeros
when the king was given this information
he had elim payne's tongue ripped out
with hot pincers
it was my desire to unite the houses of
lannister and targaryen through marriage
my daughter cersei would marry aries
eldest son prince rhaegar
such a union made perfect sense for all
parties
however
aries senses had begun to leave him
quite some time earlier
instead of uniting the royal family with
its most loyal and powerful ally
ares chose instead to insult my family
that such a match was beneath rhaegar
instead he chose elia martell of dawn to
be rhaegar's wife
as if to rub salt in my wounds ares
appointed jaime my son to the king's
guard
the king's guard may be an honor for
lesser families than ours
but it is a lifetime appointment that
forces him to renounce all family
holdings
this creates a difficulty in naming an
heir to casterly rock
but ares knew all that
i had grown tired of the king's constant
provocation
thus i resigned my post as aries hand
and returned to casterly rock
with my considerable forces
when robert baratheon rebelled against
the throne
aries grew fearful that i would join
with robert's forces and rise against
him
he thought himself clever and kept jamie
very close as if warning me
he sunk deeper and deeper into delusion
paranoia and violence
i've heard it said he became obsessed
with wildfire a substance which once lit
cannot be extinguished
convinced he had enemies all around him
he wouldn't allow blades in his presence
save for those of his king's guard
alas that proved to be his undoing